can you think of an example where you
wrote yourself into a corner and then
how you wrote yourself out yeah yeah I'm
pretty easy Tamra was a movie I wrote
myself into a corner because it was um
you know like that's a tough thing in
horror films as you create your your
villainy you make them really strong and
it's like you have to come up with a way
to stop them and you don't want to do
something super generic but you know
Tamra was kind of my homage to Carrie
about a girl who's picked on and bullied
and these kids pulled a prank on him
accidentally kill her and she's you know
in the ascription supposed to be like
really frumpy and unattractive and then
they bearer in the woods and the next
Monday she comes into school she's
really smoking hot and she knows all
their secrets and their sins and she
uses that to turn against them but I
made her you know she was really
powerful and so I'm like you know how if
I stop her it's either gonna they're
gonna to find a spell since using the
witch guy they're gonna find a spell to
stop her which is kind of you know it's
just we've seen that a hundred times
like how am I gonna and I made her so
strong that you can't kill her because
she came back from the dead so what do
you know what do I do and so I had to if
you haven't seen Tamra spoiler but no
but so I basically had the you know I
tied her fate to the teacher that she
was in love with so he ended up
sacrificing you know doing the heroic
sacrifice and like you know grabs Tamra
and jumped off a building with her and
you know sacrifices himself to stop her
so you know heroic sacrifice is always a
good way in a horror to get yourself out
of a corner because you that's the thing
when you create a monsters you have to
figure out a way to kill it and then
it's like you don't want it to be
something overly complicated but you
don't to be something as simple as a
spell the spell is killer
so yeah that I would definitely wrote
myself into a corner on with that movie
and I was like well I'll just yeah I'll
have the teacher you know sacrifice his
life to stop her and then when you got
notes let's say the first few times
around showing them what we're what were
the notes what were the feedback about
Tamra like was she too much this not
enough this Tamra was actually Tamra is
probably the easiest that was probably
the easiest project to as far as we
we found a studio that wanted to do and
they did it like it was um it was pretty
easy easy sell because I wrote that one
because I want to have fun with the
movie because I already been like
bringing something like final
destination bring us something and I you
know that's yeah and then you bring this
something L this too much like final
destination it's like stop like so if I
just wanted to write something fun and
like in my a my head and you know it was
just like a fun I wonder I like a fun
like quotable like campy sexy you know
horror movie I mean it turned out really
well I did joke because we because of
the budget you know we hit we had we had
a certain budget and then magically half
that budget like disappeared um before
when we started shooting so the movie
turned out not you know we didn't have
the money that we went in the movie
having so I always kind of joke it's
kind of like the pg-13 you know ABC
family version of an r-rated horror film
that I wrote so when you watch it you
can definitely see like a lot of places
where it's like this story got kind of
chopped out a little bit and then stuff
didn't go like wow they could have
really pushed the envelope here and they
played it really safe and that was that
was all because of like you know budget
stuff or things like that so that was
another one we were like I actually
wrote a book with a friend of mine
JD Matthews him we put it out just based
on the screenplay so that people could
see like what the original story was
like because if the only thing we had to
change on that because there were some
pretty intense stuff in there but nobody
ever said take it out but and that's
what's always funny because all the
times it's the studio that wants you to
take out stuff and play it safe and the
couple movies were that's happened to me
it hasn't been the studio that's done it
it's been like either a producer like
kind of running off with some money or
or yeah or or somebody on the on the
movie set like oh no this is yeah let's
tell them this down let's do this so
I've had the opposite of what a lot of
people have where it's like the studio
wants to play it safe like I had a
couple movies row I'm I can't believe
they're letting me get away with this
and then you get on set and then one of
the actors like I don't want to do this
and then they're like okay
oh my damn it it's like usually the
studio stops me not an actor so it's a
very again it's very it's a very
interesting business that we're in
so having final destination and and the
various ones that you were a part of
under your belt do you think that
sometimes it's difficult because they
pigeonhole you with that and you want to
do something and a little bit of a
different realm or it is it nice because
you're known for that so then they have
confidence I mean for me it's nice I
mean just because I've I'm a horror fan
and I'll probably you know I've you know
I have a science fiction kind of horror
overtones to it but a big science
fiction project right now are doing but
you know I might branch out a little bit
but I'm very happy writing horror so
I've just yeah I love the genre so and I
used to in part of its like also from
just growing up you would read in
Fangoria magazine which is like the
Bible for four people but you know you'd
read directors they would do a horror
film like well it's not really a horror
film it's more of a supernatural
thriller and they would try to say
everything but say it's a horror film
and then they would do a horror film
because they know they're gonna probably
make a profit and then they would quit
making horror and go off and do other
stuff so even directors would be like
well this is really a stepping stone to
do what I want to do and so growing up
you get really like asker you you know
this is a great Jean ruisseau you know
and it is and so yeah this is something
I am very you know embrace holy I love
going to horror conventions and and yeah
it's just a lot of fun it's a lot of
fantasy there's a greats a great fan
base and you know a lot of the you know
the people that I work with now that are
my peers were all horror fans like me we
grew up loving the same stuff and
watching the same stuff so makes it sort
of really fun community to be a part of
you